a  head in his hands as well it's the clock  it's the clock if he had one more minute  earlier he would have found that key  move the attack would have continued but  now the connection broken between words  queen and rook yeah and that bishop it's  on the long diagonal it's beautiful  piece and oh this is a killer blow from  duda  that rook is unfortunately untouchable  knight takes rook allows knight takes  night and then unfortunately the king  and queen are forked but there's no way  to defend against rook takes pawn it is  game over yeah winning in style duda the  white king running away desperately but  now the black rook can take everything  taking a pawn with check  taking the night as well and pragmata  resigns wow  that means he is down by two points in  this match against young christophe duda  what a day duda is uh having playing  some fantastic chess and he will now  only need a draw in game three to win  this match  prague he now has to win both game three  and game four